it could almost be a picture postcard of
the rhine goods barges chug up and down
the river while children explore the
pebbles on the bank
and yet a closer look shows something
else for in most summers much of this
area would be submerged but months of
high temperatures and little or no
rainfall have changed things
what we see right now with the low
water levels in rivers is the new normal
or it's even worse the new normal will
be even more extreme
we have seen a global temperature
increase of 1.2 degrees on global
average right now seen from overhead the
situation is clear
this satellite image of nearby
dusseldorf shows the river now
this one how it was in the same place 12
months ago if the science of what's
happening is clear the practical
application of it is causing problems
for many different companies the
shipping ones in particular because they
look at the right as it is now and have
real concerns about how deep it is and
how easily they can navigate it and
crucially how much each of their vessels
can carry
ships bringing salt here from heidelberg
usually carry almost 2200 tons now
they're arriving with 600 tons and that
shows the less water the less cargo on
the ships
and in this year of war in ukraine there
is another drawback with russian coal
now embargoed across the eu
many companies have paid to ship a
non-russian alternative via the rhine
instead
but as the demand has risen so the water
levels to allow it to be delivered have
dwindled
right now most shipping companies are
concentrating on the near future with
autumn just weeks away they expect its
cooler wetter weather to replenish the
rain but some scientists say that too
could bring danger if it starts to rain
on touch dry soils
the water cannot infiltrate into the
soil and we directly get surface runoff
and the water runs out of the system of
our catchment and produces
such flashlights as we know from from
california for example
the rhine has run drier in summer before
but not often it will have to rain a lot
to return the river to its more normal
state dominic kane al jazeera cologne